[UPBEAT MUSIC]
TERRY RYAN: My
name is Terry Ryan.
I'm a developer
advocate with Google.
If you have any
questions or comments,
probably the easiest
way to get them to me
is my Twitter handle--
which I forgot to put up
here, which is just tpryan.
And you can heckle me, or
ask questions, or whatever
you want to do there.
So let me get right into it.
The first question I like to
kind of put out to all you
folks is, who are you?
Helps me know, like, what
level I need to talk at,
and what jokes I can
make, that sort of thing.
So who here does
full-time systems work?
Who here does full-time
development work?
Who here does both?
Is it because you love DevOps?
Or your boss hates you,
and won't hire more people?
I saw hands go up.
Yeah.
Wait, how many people here
tell developers or systems
people what to do?
I mean, you're our bosses?
OK, good.
I should have really asked that
before I made a manager joke.
But I think we outnumber
you, so we're good.
All right, so, I have two
goals for this talk today.
First is to introduce
and showcase
the abilities of our virtual
machine platform, Google
Compute Engine.
And then I also want
to show off some
of the complimentary
technologies.
One of the other
things I will do
is, I'm going to
developer advocate.
I'm not a sales guy.
But I will talk a little
bit about pricing.
Just because from
my perspective,
a lot of the challenges
that happen with VM projects
are not technical.
They are, in fact,
usually pricing related.
People go to the cloud, and
get surprised from a pricing
perspective, and that sometimes
damages those projects.
So I will talk about
that a little bit.
But let's get right into it.
Let's get into the basics,
and talk about Compute Engine.
So Compute Engine
is our VM platform.
You can get anywhere from
0.5 to 96 processors,
although we do have larger
processor machines in beta.
160, I believe.
And then, anywhere from
0.6 to 624 gigs of RAM.
And then in beta, we have much
larger machines available.
You can attach up to 64
terabytes of standard disk,
or SSD.
And you can do three
terabytes of what
we call attached SSD, which
means in the previous 64
terabyte ones,
those are just disks
that are associated
with the machine.
Those are not, like,
physically attached.
The three terabytes of attached
SSD are kind of on the nose.
They are attached
to the hardware
that you're working with.
Which means you get much higher
performance, and much higher
IOPS out of them.
And I can go on and on
about the features and what
not, but I feel like
one of the best ways
to look at what our VMs can do
is to actually configure one.
So I'm going to do
that live for you guys.
I'm going to switch over
to the demo machine.
And let's build a VM together.
So first thing I'm
going to do is,
we see the list of all
the instances I have.
I'm going to go create one.
And let's see.
So we'll call this Delete Me.
Because I will
eventually delete it.
Let's see, let's put it in--
I can put it in any
of our data centers
that we have around the
world, but I will go with--
let's go with-- no.
I'll go with Oregon
for sentimental reasons
that will be clear later.
Let's see, so I'll put it
in AA of my options here.
Now that's going to
determine what zone,
and what region I
put it in are going
to determine some of the
capabilities of the machine.
Some zones don't have
certain processor types,
other zones have
different processor types,
or GPUs available, or what not.
And I'll show that
off in a second.
So the next thing
I want to do is,
I'm going to configure
my machine type.
And you'll see, we have a whole
bunch of pre-configured machine
types, up to 96, and the
aforementioned down here
the bottom 160 CPUs.
I'm just going to do that.
I'm going to go 160
CPUs because I can,
and Google will pay for it.
That's a lot now.
You know what, I
don't want my boss
to have to approve that
kind of expense report.
Oh, well actually, one
of the things I can do
here is instead
of just dialing in
on these pre-configured ones,
I can actually customize.
And let's say I want to do,
I don't know, 26 processors?
I can.
It's going to change the memory
profile of what I can support,
but I can do that.
I can extend the
memory if I want to.
I can choose to set a minimum
CPU platform if I want to.
And then you'll see
here that I do have
GPUs available in this zone.
I have a number of them.
I'm not going to set them
up, but they are available.
Let's see.
All right, so that's it for
the configuring the machine.
I'm actually going to go
back to a pre-configured one.
And then, let's see,
what else can I do here?
Oh, I can change the boot disk.
Right.
So you'll see, I have a number
of options for OS images
I can start with.
I can go with Ubuntu, or CoreOS,
or SUSE, or Red Hat's, or
a number of-- a couple of
Windows flavors as well if that
is the way you like to roll.
I'm going to leave
it the default.
And I can also choose
between SSD and standard.
I'm going to leave it
standard just because I'm not
going to do a lot of
computing with this disk,
with this machine.
I had this firewall
control because obviously,
one of the most common
things people do
is just open up HTTP or HTTPS.
But I can actually do a
little bit more than that.
I'll probably dig into
that a little bit.
Let's see, what are
my options here?
Security.
I can set my own
SSH keys, great.
I can encrypt my--
so all of our
disks are encrypted
by default. The only
choice you get here
is whether or not you
manage the search or we do.
Customers can supply their
keyed support to encrypt that.
It's great.
Networking.
We can look a little bit
at the network settings.
Every VM gets two
network addresses.
One is the private network,
and one is the public one.
I can turn off the public one.
I guess in theory, I can
turn off the private one.
I've never done
that because then I
don't know how I would
communicate with it,
but you in theory can.
You can give it a static
or ephemeral IP address.
You can create one.
You can reserve one.
And you can choose
between our premium
and our standard networks.
Premium network basically
uses our private backbone
to transmit all of
the data whenever--
so a customer goes and pulls
something from one of your VMs.
It's going to enter
Google's network as close
to the customer, or
the user as possible.
Was one of our PoPs, our points
of presence around the world.
And then travel on our
network to get to whatever
VM that you're going to.
If you use our standard,
we're going to operate more
like another cloud provider.
In which case, we will let it
go over the public internet
as close to it can before
it has to go on our network.
And so, with the private
network, the premium network,
you get a little bit
better, a little bit more
regular performance.
And it's on our
network the entire way,
so it's encrypted and secure.
Let's see.
What else do I
want to show here?
All right, so that's it.
Oh, one last thing I
want to show you here
before I click create is that--
so I can figure out a
whole bunch of things.
And down here at the bottom is
the equivalent REST or command
line.
I can actually click on this,
and get the exact G Cloud
command that I need to create
the machine that it configured
inside the interface here.
Which is awesome
if you're building
a whole bunch of these.
You don't have to keep going
to the console to do it.
And conversely, you don't have
to sit and kind of figure out
all the options in G Cloud.
You can just grab this, run
it, and dump it into a script,
edit it, and use it repeatedly
to build your machines.
I'm going to go
ahead and build this.
And we like to say-- or I
like to say these will spin up
in tens of seconds.
Meaning when I'm in my
hotel room practicing this,
it takes like 10 seconds.
When people are watching,
it takes longer.
I don't know how it knows.
It has performance
anxiety, I guess,
when people are watching.
But in a moment, I
should be able to see
that this is ready to go.
Hopefully, by the time I get
back here, it'll be all ready.
No, you're watching.
Oh no, there we go.
All right, good.
There's a little
SSH button here,
which is one of my
favorite features.
It's that all of these VMs,
you can just go right through.
The browser will handle pulling
down the SSH keys for you.
And you don't have to,
if you don't want to,
set up your own terminal to
connect to these machines.
So all this will happen here.
And you'll see that we're
pulling down the certs,
and I'm all ready to go.
And now I can--
I'm not going to bump
it up a little bit.
But you know, if I want to
apt-get updates as Debian.
And I'll remember that you
need to be sudo to do that.
So bang bang.
There we go.
And so there we are,
all ready to start
working with a machine,
start pulling down software.
And you know, I did it
right in front of you guys
in a couple of seconds.
Great.
OK.
So I am going to switch
back to my Preso.
Kind of talk about some of the
things that we looked at here.
Can I switch back to my Preso?
Please?
So, let's see.
What are some of the things
we talked about here?
Or I could pull up the
Preso on my own laptop,
but that would be preferential.
All right, so let's talk about
some of the things we saw here.
Oh, good.
Well, we're back.
All right, good.
All right.
They called my bluff.
All right, so first thing
is creating the VMs.
You can do this all
scripted via G Cloud.
All the options are available.
All the permutations
are ready to go.
The next step, obviously,
would be running commands.
And I was able to run command
through the SSA browser window.
But I can also do them
straight from remotely using
gcloud compute SSH
and then the command.
Also, if I want to
copy files onto it
I use gcloud compute scp
source, and then destination,
and then I'll copy files over.
So with those three
commands, I can pretty much
do a lot of migration tasks.
Right, I can build a machine,
install software on it,
and then push my code
to it, and have it run.
And so all three
of those combined,
and that's pretty much how
you would approach migration.
So talk about some
of our images.
I'm going to talk a little bit
more about disks in a moment.
But for images, we have
multiple flavors of Linux,
and multiple flavors of Windows.
You are free to
use any of those,
or bring some of
your own options,
and I'll talk about
that in a moment.
But there they are.
There's some of the options.
Next thing is, I talked
about IP addresses.
Right, we said you can
have a public or private.
You have static or ephemeral.
We will give you static--
we'll give you ephemeral
addresses by default. But
if you decide--
not of this ever
happens, right, but you
start working with
an IP address,
and realize you should
have had a static address,
and you're afraid
of losing it, you
can take any ephemeral
address that you get from us,
and just flip it over to
be static for yourselves.
And it's important to note that
it only costs you if you don't
use the static IP address.
What that means
is using ephemeral
doesn't cost anything.
If you're using static, and
it's attached to your machine,
it doesn't cost you anything.
If you use a static one, and
you pull it off your machine,
and hold onto it,
which we told there
are plenty of valid reasons
why you would do that.
It costs you when it's
not attached to a machine.
And obviously,
the incentive here
is that we would prefer you
not park a whole ton of IP
addresses, and hasten the IPv4
apocalypse that will happen
any day now, as we're told.
It'll probably happen
at the same time
the year of Linux
desktop happens.
So those are IP addresses.
Firewall.
I showed you that you can
open up HTTP or HTTPS.
The firewall--
actually, I'm going
to switch back because it
would be nice if I actually
showed the firewall controls.
So if we switch back
to the demo machine,
I'm just going to
real quick setup
a new firewall rule
on this machine.
So what I'm going to do
here is in the console,
I'm going to go over to VPC
network, firewall rules,
and we'll create a new rule.
Let's go ahead and do that.
You'll see that
I give it a name.
Let's call it MySQL.
It's got to be lowercase, mysql.
We can turn on log.
So I'm just going to leave it.
Ingress, allow/deny.
And we're going to call
the target tag MySQL.
And we will specify 3306.
Great.
And I'm just going to
say it's open to everyone
because that's great
database administration.
There we go.
And then I go back
to my machines.
VM instances, Delete Me.
I'm going to edit
this, add a tag to it.
Network tags, MySQL.
And there we go.
And just like that, this
machine is now open on port 3306
to whoever wants to get to it.
That's pretty much how
easy setting firewall
rules are for these instances.
So if you could switch
back through the Preso?
Thank you.
That's firewall.
Now let's get into some
not-so-basic stuff.
I think that's the
getting started minimum
that you need to kind of get
your machine up and running.
Let's talk about
some of the things
that make Compute Engine
maybe a little bit different.
So first we'll start
with our images.
Right, you can start
with args, which I listed
a whole bunch of them out.
But you could always
customize those images,
and then save an image.
So you can start with
our version of Debian,
download all the
software you need on it,
get it all installed
and ready to go--
but maybe not put
your coat on just yet.
And then create a
static image of it.
And then use that to build
and boot your machines.
So when you're building out
fleets of machines, that's
probably something
you need when you're
using some of our other
tools like instance scripts,
where you're making multiple
auto-scaling machines.
You actually have to do this
if you want consistency on all
the boxes as they get built.
One of the other things you can
do is boot from a container.
There's this little switch up
here that says deploy container
image to the VM instance.
When you click on that, you
get this whole other set
of options.
What you do is you point this
at a Docker repo someplace.
It could be Docker's ones
you can pull down just
from straight Docker.
Or you can use Google
Container Registry.
Build your own images,
host them there,
and then pull them down there.
It'll basically just launch
Compute Engine with container
OS and Docker running, and shove
your container in, and just
start it up.
But it's kind of
a quick easy way
to just get a container running
pretty fast on our platform.
All right, this
one is really cool.
So our Compute
Engine VMs by default
do what we call migration.
Which means that when we
do hardware or firmware
updates on the
machine, the hardware
that everything is running on,
we don't take down your VMs.
What we'll do is we'll
copy the entire memory
space, and the entire--
basically, everything
that's going on,
all the processing
and move it over to another
instance seamlessly,
without you being
able to notice.
And what this allows us to
do is we do maintenance.
You'll never see downtime
for our maintenance.
If there is hardware
failure of certain levels,
you won't see downtime.
And then, one of the
big pluses of this
is for security updates.
There's a firmware level
vulnerability for Intel--
or, I'm sorry.
It might not have been Intel.
For a processor, we
won't name names.
A while back, and a whole
bunch of our competitors,
we all had--
everybody across the
industry had this problem.
We need to update the hardware
because this is a zero day
exploit that's really scary.
We were able to do that
without it causing any downtime
to the vast majority
of customers that
had live migration enabled.
Other vendors had to have
rolling downtime in order
to handle this.
I'm actually going to show
a demo of this in action,
because one of the
things that you can do
is you can force a live
migration to happen.
So I'm going to switch
over back to demo.
And we'll see here that I have a
machine in my list of instances
called Migrate.
OK.
And that has an IP address.
So let's go to
the terminal here.
And I'm just going
to start pinging it.
OK.
And then, so that's pinging.
And then in my
other window here.
There we go.
I'll make this a
little bit bigger.
I realize you might
not be able to see it.
There you go.
But you'll see there
at the G Cloud command
to simulate a maintenance event.
Simulate a maintenance
event means tell the VM
that it's having
hardware maintenance.
And it will do a
lot of migration.
So I'm going to
hit migrate here.
And at the same time, I'm
going to bump this up.
And you'll see that we're
getting really relatively
consistent ping times.
Anywhere from 10
milliseconds to,
I've seen up to about
200 milliseconds.
Some of this is obviously
dependent on the network
that I'm running on because
it has to go from this machine
to Google.
But we are moving this
machine right now.
And you'll see that there's
almost no disruption.
Now, if you have a more
advanced service, if you--
like, because I'm
just doing a ping.
Right, that's not that
taxing on the machine.
What we've seen is that
you won't drop connections.
But some connections may
take just a little bit longer
to answer while it's in
the process of migrating.
But we are still
migrating, and we
haven't seen any downtime yet.
And we won't because we're done.
And we've just moved the machine
from one piece of hardware
to another without us
seeing it surface at all
at the connectivity level.
What you guys think of that?
Is that something
you guys could use?
No?
Oh, OK.
All right, tough room guys.
You just had the keynote, right?
All right, so I'm going to
switch back to my Preso.
And we'll go a little
bit deeper into stuff.
All right, so some
of the options
that I didn't touch here is that
you absolutely can attach GPUs
to your machines.
We have several types of GPUs
available, mostly Nvidia.
Tesla K80s, P100s, P4s,
T4s, and V100 GPUs.
Now it's important I put this
right after live migration
because these are things
that are especially
attached to the harbor
that you're running.
And so basically, you
can't do the live migration
with them running.
Right, if you are running GPUs,
you cannot do a live migration
operation.
Which kind of makes
some sense, right,
because we have to
have the hardware,
and the hardware is good.
We also have available
something called
TPUs, which are Google's
custom tensor processing
units that are optimized
for ML operations.
Ooh, that's a bad spelling.
They are now available
for preemptible pricing.
And I'll talk a little bit
about preemptible pricing
when I get to the
pricing section.
But basically, if
you have advanced--
or, you just have ML work,
and you want to kind of turbo
charge it.
Switching to GPUs and activating
that option in your tensor
flow or Cloud MLE, or Cloud
Machine Learning Engine boxes
will make those operations
faster, and ultimately cheaper.
We're going to take
a slight detour.
And I want to talk about
something called Cloud Shell.
So a lot of times, people
set up VMs, and set them up
as a workstation.
Right, they have one systems
workstation that they setup,
and use that to connect to their
entire cloud infrastructure.
And you can do that.
We're happy to have you do that.
But we also have Cloud Shell
available for you, which is
a browser-based terminal, CLI.
You saw the SSH window
that we kind of give you,
but we also have it
kind of hooked up
to a custom VM that is
always available for you.
It has a home directory, so you
can store commonly used scripts
there, and have them
migrate with you
as your you're working on them.
But we don't charge
you anything for it,
so you can just always
have it available.
And I'm going to switch
back, and show it.
Just how to get to
it, and how to use it.
Up here at the top
of my console there's
this little terminal
looking thing.
I'm going to go ahead
and activate Cloud Shell.
See, it's going to
provision a machine for me.
And I can always open
this in a new window.
And we'll see that we're
establishing our connection.
What's great about
this is I don't
have to maintain any of
the software on here.
I can use G Cloud projects.
Projects list.
And so G Cloud is
running on this.
It's all up to date.
It's all the latest version.
Same thing with the
Kubernetes controls.
Same thing with most of
the kind of universally
used on Google Cloud tools.
They're all updated
already for you to use.
So I'm going to switch back.
And, oh, let's talk
about metadata.
So one of the cool things that
we have built into our platform
is the metadata platform.
So whenever you're using
one of our machines,
you have access to
this storage space.
It's a key value storage
space where you can find out
information about your VM,
you can find information
about your project, or you
can even put and take out
custom metadata.
And I actually do have
a quick demo for this,
just because it's
kind of interesting.
So almost switch back here.
And I'm going to go and I
have some commands already
written out because
they're long.
So let me go ahead and
copy and paste this.
And let's go to--
and we're going to log into the
Delete Me machine that I made.
And we're going to try
and find some stuff out.
So what's really
helpful about this?
If you're doing
anything that you
need to pull the IP
address of the machine,
or you want to write
code that you don't have
the hard code any of the
names of machines into,
but when you're running, grab
the name of the machine from,
or different things
about the project.
You can pull them from here.
So what I want to
do is drop this in.
And you'll see, I
have the entry there.
But basically I
just cURLed metadata
dot Google internal, compute
metadata, instance name,
and I got--
where did it go?
It was there a second ago.
There you go.
Delete Me, that was the
name of the machine.
And I could also do that
at the project level.
Right, so I can go back
here, and grab this one.
So again, a lot of times
I'm writing custom code,
and I don't want to know--
I don't want to hard code any
other project details into it.
I could just use
this, and get this.
One important thing is
that you want to always
make sure you include that
header down at the end of it,
the metadata flavor Google.
Otherwise it'll return an error.
But basically, any of the
SDK for any of the language
run-times that you
might run on here
usually have this built
in so they can just
pull this information.
But you can get to it directly,
and deal with it however
by just grabbing the URLs.
This is all secure.
So for machine metadata,
it's actually doing a process
under the covers.
And the know, the
request, and the data
never leaves the VM itself.
For project, I also
believe that it's
grabbing data that's locally.
But I have not--
I'm not I'm 100%
certain of that.
But just be aware that you can
trust that that data is not
being transmitted anywhere.
All right, I'm going to
switch back to Preso.
Metadata.
So now, let's talk
about pricing.
And like I said, pricing
is a giant hurdle,
I think, a lot of
times with VM projects.
And basically, the logic
goes something like this.
It used to be the case
where you over-buy hardware.
Right, because you're going
to amortize it over three,
or five, or eight years.
And so you want it to be
able to grow to your usage
three to five years from now.
So you over-buy, which
is totally valid strategy
when you're doing on-prem
stuff because you're
planning for growth.
But then you do
that same process,
and you go, oh, well
I'll go to the cloud.
And I had, you know,
10 64 CPU boxes.
I'm just going to repeat
that, and do the same thing.
And you get this bill
that sort of outrageous.
And that combined with the
fact that you're not actually
using all of that processing
power means that you're not
just overpaying, you're
overpaying for stuff
that you're not using.
Right, so we have
a couple of things
to encourage strategies for
you to kind of curb your usage
to kind of conform to
the way that you'll
get the best pricing on us.
Wow that was a complex
sentence I just said there.
All right, so let's start
with the first one, which
is our sustained use discount.
So one of the--
I kind of talked to that whole
process where you over-buys,
and you plan for growth.
Well, we do that too.
Right, so we take on a risk, and
buy extra machines in the hopes
that people will use
them, and pay us for them.
That risk is still there, and
that's still a risk for us.
So any time that we can push
that risk onto our customers,
we'll make a deal.
Right, we'll lower the price
because it's good for us
to share some of this risk.
So if you have long-running
machines, that's good for us.
Because the longer
and more consistent
you guys are running
machines, the more easy
we can plan for growth.
Right, because it's
more consistent.
So we like regular usage.
We like long-running machines.
So the longer you
use the machines,
the longer we'll
give you a discount.
So you get up to 30%
off of our list price
over the course of a
month for running a VM.
Now it's important
to note that this
is calculated over
all of your instances,
and not just one or two.
So for example, if you spin
up a box for half a month,
and then spin up another
box for half a month,
we'll actually combine that
into a full month of a box
even though they were separate.
We call that inferred instances.
So let me show
you how this looks
from a machine standpoint.
So day one, end of month,
I start with one machine,
and I run it for half the month.
And then I need to add
additional capacity,
so I'm running a second machine
also for part of the month.
I add a third machine for
the back half of the month.
And then I add some extras.
Right, so I'm running
five machines total.
None of them are running
for a full month.
So you wouldn't
necessarily expect
to get the full discount.
But what we do is we
lump these all together.
Right, so we cut off five,
and split it into this.
And basically, we kind
of go from the start
of when the machine
ran the earliest,
and then plan out
for a whole month.
We'll see that one
and three combine
to become a full machine.
Two, four, and five combine to
become majority of a machine.
And five is a partial.
So then we calculate
the discount
by saying, OK, this
set of machines
that we're counting as one gets
100% of the discount, 30% off.
The second one ran for
about 80% of the month,
so we'll give it 80%
of that discount.
And then the fifth one ran for
just around 25% of the month.
And so that's how we'll
calculate your sustained use,
not just on each individual
part as it relates to a month.
So the more you run,
the cheaper we are,
and we're happy to have
your consistent usage.
OK.
So that sustained use discount.
And the great thing
about that is you
don't have to do anything.
I mean other-- if
you want to game it,
you can certainly kind
of make sure you're
getting the best one you want.
But if you run a VM, we just
apply this automatically.
There's no switch you
have to flip or anything.
So the next pricing control
we have is something
called committed use discount.
And we fought this
for a long time
because committed use struck
us as decidedly uncloud-y.
Right, you're taking
a machine and saying
I will run this machine
for three years.
I'll run this
machine for one year.
Which basically, you just
moved your hardware commitment
from your data center
to us without really
taking advantage of the fact
that we're on the cloud.
If you need more,
you can ask for more.
If you need less,
you can ask for less.
So we do it a little
bit differently.
You're not committing
yourself to a machine.
You're not saying, I
will have this one 64
core box for the
next three years.
You're paying for an allotment
of processors and RAM.
And we'll give you up
to 50% off depending
on their configuration
and whatnot.
But here's the thing,
you can configure
this however you want, and
you can change it at any time.
So let's say I agree
to buy 300 20 cores.
Memory would also apply,
but it would make the math
a lot uglier.
And I can't do math on the fly.
So we'll just say,
for sake of argument,
this is just our
processor allocation.
Memory is also involved, but
we're not going to show it.
So I have 300 20 cores.
I split it up into
16 20 core boxes.
Great.
Further down the road, I
figure out that, like, man,
I really need a
beefier machine to do
this one set of operations.
What I can do is tear
down four of the 20s,
and turn it into an 80.
And this is still
the same thing,
so it's still the same discount,
still the same everything
because it's the same
number of processors total.
And I can do it the other way.
Right, I can go lower.
I can break up some of
my machines into smaller.
I can do whatever.
As long as I'm still at the
same processor allocation,
the committed use
discount will apply,
and all of our agreements
are all in place.
Which is great.
Now, if you need
more, obviously, you
can do committed use along
with other strategies.
You can just buy an extra VM.
But once you commit
to this, you will
pay for the term of your
commitment regardless.
So that is another way.
All right, so that has
been pricing tricks.
And now I want to talk about
some of our usage controls.
So we have something
called custom VMs.
I showed you, you can
dial in exactly the number
of processors and
memory that you wanted.
And what this allows you
to do is a lot of times,
you look at those preset
configurations for machines.
Right, you've got your
two, your four, your eight,
your 16, your 32, your 64.
But like, you may find
that one of your processes
runs perfectly at 20 processors.
Right, that's the optimal.
So you're kind of
left with a choice.
Do you under spec
at 16, and maybe not
be as performing as
you possibly can be?
Or do over spec at 32?
And just say well, I'll waste
that money because, you know,
I'm not paying.
My bosses is paying it.
But what you can do is dial
in exactly to 20 with us,
and get the exact performance
you need for as little money as
possible as you can pay for it.
And actually, I
have a demo of this.
So I'm going to switch
back to the machine here.
And I'm going to start
this off, and then
explain what I'm
doing because it does
take about two minutes to run.
So I have here, you'll see, 64--
I'm sorry, 32
machines ready to go.
And I'm calling out to the APIs
to request machines for them.
And you'll see that's
two, four, six.
It's all the permutations
of custom VMs I can use.
What's going to happen is these
boxes are going to spin up.
And they're going to calculate
100 million digits of pi
on each box as soon
as they start up.
The reason why I do
that is because that
is a very processor
intensive operation.
But the tool that
we use for crunching
pi, kind of at some point, you
don't get better performance
by adding more processors to it.
And so what's going
to happen is all
of these machines
are going to spin up,
and we'll see which one
does it the fastest.
And we'll also see
which one does it the,
like, optimal
performance for cost.
So the first part of
what we're doing here
was the requesting
from our data center.
So basically, we say, hey.
We would like a VM.
And the data center takes
a little bit of time
to figure out, do we
have capacity for this?
Yeah.
We do, or we don't.
But it looks like in most
cases, we did have capacity.
The next thing it does is build.
All right, so we're going to
take the processor and memory
configuration that
you asked for.
Find it in the data center,
kind of lump them together,
and then turn them
into a machine.
After we build, we're going
to configure the network
to make sure that it can
talk publicly and privately.
And then after it
does that, it's
obviously going to boot
its operating system.
And then the first
thing it does,
after it's all done
its boot operations,
that it immediately calculates
100 million digits of pi
using y-cruncher.
So we'll see this is happened.
We'll see.
I wonder which one
is going to win?
I know which one is
optimal because I've
done this hundreds of
times, but it always
surprises me which one wins.
There is no real
difference in terms
of speed of a boot process by
how you configure your machine.
It used to be that the
custom numbers were
a little bit longer because
we already pre-allocated
some of the pre-set numbers.
That doesn't seem to
be the case anymore.
And so, let's see.
We already have a winner.
The winner was-- wow, the screen
is so big that I can't tell.
I can't read it from here.
Let's see.
So 40 processors won.
But we're still chugging along.
Like I said, this usually takes
about two minutes to finish.
We're just going to
let it finish out.
And when it's done,
what we're going to do
is we're going to isolate
just the pi calculation,
and look at the
curve it creates.
We're done that one.
And that one should
be done any second.
So a lot of interesting
observations.
40 won.
But a lot of the
high performing ones
were sort of down here in
the lower processor range.
So let's isolate pi calculation.
And you'll see that
we get a nice curve.
Right, this is definitely
processor related.
But eventually it
kind of craps out,
and it doesn't get any
better just because you
add more processors to it.
Having done this
hundreds of times,
it's around 28
processors, is where
it starts to become kind of--
you're not getting benefits
out of adding more machines.
But as we see, 20--
in terms of the total cost
of how much this costs,
we go from the
smallest thing we could
do, a two processor box, all the
way up to a 64 processor box.
And our price starts at 0.2
cents for that operation,
all the way up to 6.5
cents for the operation.
So one, we just calculated
100 million digits of pi
on multiple machines that we
spun up from nothing just right
now, which is kind of cool.
And we were able to figure out
what the optimal processor was
for this, or about 28.
So that's great.
I'm going to switch
back to my Preso.
And let's see.
So that was custom VMs.
Now let's talk about
preemptible VMs, which
is another strategy we have.
Preemptible VMs are 1/5th
the cost of our normal VMs.
So just right out the
door, just 1/5th the cost.
However, they will
disappear in 24 hours.
Sometime in the next 24
hours, they'll go away.
It could be any time
in that 24 hours,
but they'll definitely
go away within 24 hours.
You'll lose the machine.
You have about a 30
second warning before it
just kind of goes away.
But then what you can do is you
can always request another one,
and we'll give it to you.
So what is this for?
It's not for running your
permanent, you know, e-commerce
or website presence.
It's not for anything
that's user-facing.
It's for bash work.
It's for work that you don't
care when it gets done.
Right, it can support having an
interruption, and restarting.
So cue processing, batch
work, anything like that.
So
Let's kind of show
how this would work.
So I have a machine here.
This is the-- what is this?
This is the micro.
We're going to bump
it to the one CPU.
We're going to bump it to 32.
And then we're going to bump
it all the way up to 96.
And when we get there, we
see that the price per month
is $2,300.
As calculated, that's $3,300
for the actual full cost of it.
And then you're getting $1,000
off in the sustained use
discount if you're running
it for the full month.
And that's how we
arrive at $2,300.
With preemptible VMs, what you
get is, the total cost drops--
sorry, the original
cost drops to $701
because it's 1/5th
of that $3,500.
But you don't get the
sustained use discount,
and then it comes out at $701.
So this is a really
great strategy
for lowering the
cost for operations
that don't need to happen
at a particular time,
particular moment.
AUDIENCE: Can you speak--
TERRY RYAN: The--
I'm sorry, is there a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can you speak to to the restart?
So you don't know when
you're going to go down?
TERRY RYAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you bring
yourself back up when
you do it five times a day.
Say you've only got
a four hour slot.
How does that actually work?
TERRY RYAN: That's
a great question.
So one, you can always
just do it manually.
Right, you have to check
to see if it's up, and--
right, but we do
want to do that.
The way most of our
customers who are using this
as a strategy do it, they--
and I'm going to talk
about this right now.
Instance groups.
Where you can create
these groups that you say
have a minimum, a maximum,
and have them always running.
You can set them
to be preemptible.
So if one of those machines goes
down, it'll start backed up.
And that's probably the
best strategy for doing it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How will
these preemptible VMs
be before they go?
[INAUDIBLE]?
TERRY RYAN: No.
So they will live at some time.
They will live for
up to 24 hours.
So that is the
longest they'll live.
But they can, in theory,
shut down immediately
after you start them up.
Because what's happening
under the covers is,
we have machines that
aren't being used,
allocated in certain
ways, and certain data
centers, and whatnot.
And when you ask for one
of these preemptible VMs,
you're saying I want it, but
I don't want it that badly.
Right, so what will happen
is within that 24 hours,
if another customer comes
along and says, no, no.
I need this machine
all the time.
And I'm going to pay
the full price for it.
We say, well that's the deal
we made, and we'll take it.
So that's why you don't have
any control over how long--
because like, maybe
no one asks for it.
You get it the whole 24 hours.
Maybe someone asks
for it immediately,
and it's taken away.
All right?
I'm going to try to get
through this next section,
and I'll leave time for
questions at the end.
So as I was saying before,
one of the things--
once you want to
start scaling out,
once you want to start making
your operations bigger,
or a little bit more
self-managing, what you're
going to want to do is take
the next step towards managed
and unmanaged instance groups.
These are groups of machines
that are all connected to a--
well, they're
groups of machines.
That's really all they
are under the covers.
They're not that useful
unless you hook them up
to a load balancer,
in which case
then you can have them
share responsibilities.
But if you have a managed
or unmanaged group.
Managed groups, you have to
create an image template.
So you'll create a disk
like I outlined before.
You'll create a machine profile.
And you will say this is
the template for this,
and create machines in this
group to this template.
Then, because they're
all exactly the same,
we can do things like
auto-scale and auto-heal them.
You can say, have the process
utilization always be 60%.
And so if it goes above
60%, we will spin up
more instances for you.
If it drops below 60%
over all your instances,
we will spin down
one to you, for you,
with you being able
to set min and max.
So you may want to just
say min three all the time.
Just so I have some redundancy,
and also some redundancy.
And then set an upper limit,
like this should never
go to 20 machines.
So if it does, there's a
problem, so have the max be 20.
Unmanaged groups are again
a collection of machines
that you hook up
to a load balancer.
The only difference here is
that they're heterogeneous.
And because they're
heterogeneous,
we really can't do
no auto nothing.
Right, like we don't
know the impact
of adding another
machine because you
have all different sets
of processors allocations.
That's fine.
So you can set
these up this way.
And then finally, you're going
to want to hook one of these
up to our load balancers.
And we have a couple different
flavors of load balancer.
Our HTTP HTTPS load
balancer, which
is sort of the equivalent of
what other people would refer
to as an L7 load balancer.
TCP and UDP are
network load balancers
that are running at L4.
And then either of
these, you can set up
to be internal only so that it's
only routing internal traffic.
Now I'm going to walk through
the console of these things
real quickly.
But I'm not going
to set anything up
because it usually takes
a little bit of time.
So I'm going to switch
to the demo monitor here.
Oh yeah, perfect.
And let's look at this.
So let's see here.
We're going to start
with our instance groups.
Now I have an instance
group already setup.
You'll see that I have
three instances running.
And I have a rule
that the target CPU
utilization is always 60.
We can go in, and we can
see this is a managed group
so that it will
auto-scale and all this.
I have a template set up for it.
I'm just going to go through.
I'm going to mess around
with the minimums here.
I'm going to say a minimum
five instead of three.
And then I'm going to
set the maximum to 10.
And I'll save that.
And all of this is wired
up to a load balancer.
So let me go here, and
we'll see the load balancer.
And this is pretty
basically straightforward.
I get a front end, which is
my IP address, in which case
this is an HTTP load balancer,
so it's doing mostly HTTP.
And I can set up
host paths and rules,
or I can just have
it just completely
load balance the whole thing.
But I could setup
multiple back-ends
to work on different paths
on the front-end here.
I have a lot of
control over that.
And then down here, I
have my back-end services,
which was that instance group
I just showed you earlier.
And so if I go to
this IP address,
you'll see my really exciting
default Apache web page.
Because I was really kind of
throwing this together quickly.
There we go.
So that's running.
So one of those
boxes is responding.
And then finally, in that
last step, I at some point
updated the number of machines.
And we'll see that
it is currently
spinning up those machines.
Basically, it's in the process
of creating them right now.
So that's why they're
kind of labeled red.
But because I said minimum
five instead of minimum three,
that's why it's
spinning up more.
All right, I'm
looking at my time,
and I'm looking at
my Preso, so I'm
going to switch back
to the presentation.
And let's see.
So a couple of
quick conclusions.
One, there are other
products in the GCP
that use Compute Engine as the
underpinnings for the product.
For example, Kubernetes Engine
is using straight Compute
Engine VMs under the covers.
And same thing with Dataflow,
Dataproc, and Cloud Shell.
Why is this relevant?
Why is this important?
Because you can use
some of the strategies
you would use maintaining
Compute Engine instances
with these products.
For example, Kubernetes Engine
is for managing containers.
You're running host nodes
that run Kubernetes on it.
You can do things like create
a managed instance group that
is made up of entirely
preemptible VMs,
and have that support
your container work.
So you can dramatically
lower the cost
of running a Kubernetes
Engine cluster
by moving some of the
work onto preemptible VMs
because you can set it up
all through Compute Engine.
Same kind of strategies apply
for Dataflow and Dataproc.
And Cloud Shell has access
to the metadata too.
So all of these things add up.
You may want to look at
applying some of the stuff
that we talked about here to
one of our these other products.
Also, you get a free
tier of Compute Engine
just by having a project.
So your first F1 micro
instance is free in perpetuity.
So it's not a very beefy box.
It's a shared processor
with six gigs of RAM,
but if you just want to
play around, and start
fooling around VMs if
you haven't already,
you can use that, and
kind of dip your feet in.
With that, I will say this
was, for me, a new talk.
So please feel free
to give me feedback.
Obviously, if you
liked it, great.
But if you have
constructive feedback,
I would definitely
love to hear it.
So do that through the Next App.
All right, thank you everybody.
And like I said, I'll be
around if you have questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[UPBEAT TECHNO MUSIC]